by this time each summer portugal's bars
and beaches are usually packed with uk
holiday makers
but covid 19 has kept them away and
quarantine rules are likely to deter
many from flying in anytime soon it's a
worry for business owners on the algarve
who are struggling and know that the
price of a week in the sun here
will mean two weeks stuck at home for
people if they return to england
there is literally nobody here to to
to provide any drinks for um or any food
for
so we remain closed basically like
everybody else there is very few uh
very few places that are able to open at
the moment his worry is shared by many
who
rely heavily on the 2.1 million visitors
from the uk
who usually visit portugal each year the
country was left off a list of more than
50 nations
regarded as safe enough for travel
without restriction
portugal's government has gone on the
attack especially over the uk's own
record
on kovid
when a country with 28 times more deaths
from covenant 19 than portugal
wants to impose a quarantine to
passengers coming from portugal
i'd say the problem isn't in portugal
the problem is in that country
only this week portugal's prime minister
along with spanish officials
held a ceremony to mark the re-opening
of borders during the critical summer
tourist season
spain has had to reintroduce a lockdown
in the catalonia region
because of new outbreaks of coronavirus
but the country is on the quarantine
free list unlike
portugal in the entire country the
situation is perfect
we had no deaths in madeira for instance
the algarve represents only one percent
of the total cases in portugal
so we really don't understand it it was
quite a surprise
and and there's a big disappointment the
disappointment is for the economy and
jobs
portugal had hoped to lure back visitors
and make up for months of lost income
but the prospect of quarantine will
hardly provide an incentive
for people to travel michelle clifford
sky news
brussels